so what a great pass by Alonzo and
JaVale says thank you has played Alonso
made pass look at the wall in the air he
knows he got a guy JaVale running before
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time out Dallas Houston cut that lead of
15 down to 9 if they can turn them over
and run they're all right 37% right now
as they turn it over again that's it's a
guy thing
nutmeg my better days sad dog that's
Chandler that you try to go through the
legs of Lonzo maybe quite work you made
a kick saving a beauty Forte is that the
Lakers have two good rim protector he
was trying to make the play in Lonzo
right there as you mentioned to make the
steal and get the assist
[Applause]
but you can't miss the baby shots down
to one in Murray around the corner
JaVale McGee at seven blocks in a game
recently running out it's Brandon to
Ingram yeah 42% one point two percent
one
[Applause]
Kuzma huh whatever they never change
their mind come we're coming back with
the bird tied the game that's a great
pass to LeBron James and it's 61 56
Kuzma gets a running start Nikki but
unselfish fine bye ball that time still
shocked yeah a 24 year old son you look
30 deep
Rosen I'm Kuzma running the floor throws
it down and one of the quickest paces in
the NBA block down to seven Mucha [ __ ]
and it taken away by ball three on three
James trailing the play makers will run
with Lonzo good pass to LeBron James
wonderful assist from Lonzo ball is away
trying to get in transition of an
abundant community look out beetles down
and Derrick Rose trying to throw it
ahead towns turned his back and a
turnover the Minnesota beautiful pass to
England
excellent port fishin Alonso vol 14th if
this one goes down it does not weak side
rebound taken by Alonso perfect outlet
now to Koosman he's under he scores SIOC
up in the corner here at Joey's going to
be off Lonzo collects it outlet got it
Ingram here he goes water to get the
rebound and as Lonzo did and then pushes
it out Brandon Ingram with that length
of his can get to the front of the rim
rather easily
[Music]
Kuzma
[Applause]
both of these teams today that Williams
will pick up the family straight away
three home runs the floor and eager
Kokoschka
is Silom are heavy and lofty
expectations for his Laker team Lakers
get started up top they go to McGee and
just like that
make your strike tuned up to pick up the
ball and they fire in trouble passes up
[Music]
[Applause]
whoo that was some play and then LeBron
caps it off with a three-point
opportunity to put the Lakers up
possibly by sea